is it recording mm-hmm okay hello
YouTube um I'm back with a guest in the
national master Costa ku boots key hey
guys and we tried to stream some game
analysis yes a few minutes ago and the
romanian Wi-Fi we thought was good but
it turned out to be bad so now we're
gonna do a recording for YouTube yeah
which hopefully will be good like
hopefully we won't get too distracted by
the twitch chats and we can actually
give some insightful analysis and we're
playing a tournament we're playing the
fisca open it's a nine round tournament
game a day except for a few game a few
days to have two games I don't think we
mentioned where or we did we're in
Romania yes
exciting tournament the games are all or
some of the games are broadcast on just
24 daily and what we're doing is just
going over our games after every round
just giving you a pretty now I'm gonna
put the link to chess 24 in the youtube
description or whatever so you can watch
live if you're awake at the time the
games are being played you can also go
and like replay the games they're
broadcasting the top 11 games right and
I'm the 12th seed so my my games at
least for the first few rounds will not
be broadcast but eventually they will
yeah hopefully they better be the top I
keep if I don't mess up right so okay
this one I guess won't start with my
game yeah let's do it
I was playing a 1700 kid named Andre
Christian manescu and and we should know
the sections pretty big there's about
160 players no accelerated pairings so
we both played substantially weaker
players in the first round
yeah pretty down but it wasn't easy okay
so we got the time on of Sicilian this
has been one of my main lines last few
years after the game he told me that he
didn't know the opening at all which is
surprising considering
he gets like a very very good position
at one point and definitely outplayed me
well he goes for Queen d2 kind of
typical English attack I think it made
sense here you played f3 Bishop b4 and
a3 so he chose kind of a funny move
order normally they play castles here
and then only after Bishop before they
play f3 but he he played this first I
think he's just simply making natural
moves but it's tricky because now Bishop
b4 a3 I don't really want to take and
give up the dark squared Bishop I was
saying earlier d5 but I guess yeah it's
it's playable for whites yeah I don't
really what did we say like Knight takes
c6 Bishop t4 I think this would be a
potential problem to bishops comunism
the darks for Bishop yeah is so strong
here that well I would hesitate to go
into this unless I knew for sure it was
like good for black I think next time
after a three you should look into 95 oh
right because yeah this move I didn't
know about but it makes a lot of sense
because now it doesn't make sense for
him to play f4 and just lose this tempo
but yeah that makes sense I think I've
been playing time on off longer than you
so and always one of the first things I
learned to play 95 against f3 oh I see
yeah I never I never looked into the
line I figure I'm just gonna go back and
we'll play this middle game where of
course he's gonna Castle queenside and
then I have this hook on a 3-2 to mess
with b5 and b4 that's actually the great
thing about time on if you don't
necessarily need to know a theory you
just know like structures and you know
the general plans pretty playable gets
you to certain points well he castles I
played b5 and here he decides to take on
c6 which I think is okay it's a normal
move it's probably not the most critical
I imagine g4 here is probably the main
line actually this would be a good time
to plug my patreon page if you guys
haven't seen it before I have a page on
patreon where I do a bunch of chess
analysis I always go over my games of
applying any tournaments and here we'll
just be analyzing most of the game but
if you want a little bit more detail on
the open
or if you want to download the the
annotated PGN you should check that out
I'm sure we'll include a link in the
description that you can click load the
video yes it'll be very very easy for
you to find that but yeah if you want to
see more comments specifically on the
opening I don't want to give away too
much of my my prep on YouTube so you'll
have to visit I don't think this is
proud to bishop before Bishop e7 yeah
but I think I'll go in and try to UM
maybe investigate a bit deeper
ninety-five move is really really good
ok so he took on c6 and this is the line
recommended by by Negi in his efore
repertoire but without the pawn on a3 so
black basically gave white this free
move Bishop before Bishop e7 and here he
he made a weird move Knight a2 which i
think is not very good objectively he
was obviously worried about before and
wanted to prevent this but the problem
is that block is eventually just gonna
play a 5 before anyway and so he's not
really stopping anything what should he
do in this position so better move would
have been g4 and the main plan for white
here is to play h4 and Bishop h3 mm-hmm
and you wouldn't play b4 immediately I
might mm-hmm yeah in the mainline the
spawns on a 2 right and so b4 night a4
gives nothing but here it's like well
you do take the pawn because you get the
Bishop to b4 Queen 85 yeah so this I
would really consider because I do have
to be careful about the d8 square it's
true mated well I'm not counseled yeah
but Queen 85 still covers it like Bishop
f4 maybe I could play Queen a 521 just
wins yeah I mean that would be that
might be disastrous of course I have to
watch out for this and that would be
that would be bad for me but Queen a
five-way whoa 85 this is 85 Queen Oh
Queen a5 we're not attacking the bishop
yeah yes please King b1 probably true um
okay 25 here it's probably good I don't
know I didn't I didn't think about this
one too much it definitely looks like
something I should consider when I play
low rate of players I try not to
predict their moves because they always
surprise me so if he plays g4 I would
start thinking of the truth he turned
out to play Knight a2 so like yeah it
was no no use for me to analyze that
line too deeply but I mean this position
it looks reasonable I don't have rook b8
which is unfortunate but I can castle
and then like I don't know what to do
after King b1 I guess
can you play e5 Bishop to g5 there
should be six just an initiative yeah
someone like this a ships attack this
would make sense I'll play like Bishop
takes c3 Queen a to eventual like rook
d8 anything ideas
yeah you can't play Bishop d3 here's one
because I do take mmm and so yeah or I'm
throwing to take right away so you would
have to do something maybe he takes I
don't know that seems to double edge but
just seems like you have so much power
it's like two bishops opened e-file yeah
no I would I would definitely take like
here I think I think this is probably
good um well yes and maybe 92 I don't
know it seems well I would imagine
Knight takes c6 then his dubious if g4
if g4 be for is just good for a block
then he shouldn't be taking on c6 and he
should just play like g4 right away
because the difference here is that he
can put his knight on v3 I imagine I was
thinking about something like this
during the game trying to figure out if
I would have some play here that looks
reasonable open B Philemon and so on but
anyways okay he takes he plays Knight a2
and I play d5 which I I don't think it
was really necessary I think it's
definitely a decent move here but I feel
like a five would have just been a lot
easier because I stopped his knife for
coming to b4 and then in many positions
I'm just starting to play B for myself
because I always have like rook a one
check at the end and I don't really need
to play e5 right away there is a common
idea for white to play e5 himself I
thought he might go for this actually
because if I take he has Bishop f4 and
if I go this way I think my queen just
gets drawn his queen gets kicked around
and if queen c5 he just repeats Bishop
III yeah maybe he has something better
about okay from my point of view of
repetition is unacceptable so I would
probably play 95 this is usually fine
for black and we just get some kind of
pseudo French it so looks good with a
pawn on e3 yeah he said the father an a3
is helpful for me here so I would have
been okay with this for sure okay in any
case 92 e5 is played night before so I
felt like his idea was to play Queen C 3
and then either Bishop c5 or 93 first
and clamped down on this square so I
realized I should be precise here and
then I kind of overthought things one of
my first ideas was to play c5 which I
think would have just given black a good
position because if he plays Knight d5
we can trade Queen d5 Bishop d7 he just
has to go back and I think it's just
easier to attack on the Queen side and
after II d5 I play Bishop d6 I just I
get this nice blockade I just Castle
maybe even Bishop f5 rook c8 and just
looks really really easy for black to
play and really difficult for white to
because his pawns are just so slow
moving on the Kings side so to me this
just looks like a very real advantage
for black but then I was just looking
for something better and then I
convinced myself that I found it even
though I don't think I did because I
chose Bishop b7 just improving the
bishop but this show really belongs on
e6 here he plays 93 c5 and Queen c3
I think visually it still looks good for
black just more space yeah I thought you
had to come I think right I think at
this point I should Castle yeah instead
of c5 although I feel like Bishop e7 is
just not a good move
how do I Castle dear Queen c3 see the
problem is if I play 97 he does get
Knight c5 in here I think Wyatt is
actually maybe slightly better because
his queen just gets just very nicely
placed and so like this respond b7
dominates everything really really bad
yeah yes so at this point I'm not sure
what I should have done maybe I should
play maybe even a 5
who's the Queen c3 can potentially meet
with with b4 but yeah in any case Bishop
d7 I think I got a was a real just not a
good move I think c5 is just kind of
easy for black but ok this should be 793
I played while I play ninety someone
first actually Queen c3 and c5 and so
here I thought I was doing fine because
all the pawns are defended and I'm gonna
play c4 castles 85 b4 and then he hits
me with g3 which very strong move
definitely the best in the position and
I realized that he's just gonna play
Bishop h3 Bishop takes d7 and my
position is gonna collapse because this
Knight is holding everything together
and I'm just not in time so if I start
to I don't know play rugby 8 Bishop h3
and I don't know even like Bishop d6
well you can take on d7 and I just don't
have a good way to take back rook takes
your pawns or targets
yeah yeah just losing upon said so yeah
this looked really scary I mean I
definitely panicked
and kind of lucky I even have a way out
which I ended up finding basically
through a process of elimination because
block just has nothing else
so castles Bishop h3 and he's always
taking on d7 if my queen ever shows up
here then his rook you know is opened up
and he just takes on e5 even if my pawns
on f6 he can just take here and or on c5
and I'm dead lost like he just found
better squares for his pieces in
relations yeah that's on d7 e5 c5 Milan
d3 so strong yeah well this is the
problem with being ambitious is that
sometimes you can get caught especially
with black because you are kind of
behind in development well I found the
only move got five and in the game he
ends up taking right away which i think
is just a serious mistake because it
allows me to simplify the position and
then I feel like black ends up being
perfectly okay in fact I won the game a
few moves later during the game I felt
like the most dangerous would be just
any kind of move that improves this
position and keeps the tension because
everything and my camp is just just very
loose and hanging and both of these
pawns are weak and now f5 is hanging if
I take on e4 you can probably take on d7
and this just looks like I don't know
maybe I take here Queen takes maybe Rick
takes but I don't know I wasn't too sure
about this I feel like he can also look
for another move like night b4 here
might be very strong you're just somehow
hitting the night I don't know maybe
there's some something concrete he can
do that looks strong probably throwing
in the check is also useful anyways yeah
something like this and I think the
engine gives like +1 so clearly white is
doing very well there I think after Rick
h1 I might have to play like g6 and then
my position is just as very weak is
Bishop h6 and so many things but he took
which is understandable I mean he
calculated the line you know material is
gonna be equal and
it seems like it might be okay for white
but I think black just kind of gets out
and if I'm able to defend these pawns
and I'm doing fine
so he played g4 here I think it makes
sense and I decided to just keep it
simple take the rook c4 and now I got
rid of one of my weaknesses I get the c5
square and I felt like in the game he
should play Knight f2 just trying to
play 94g v f6 like this but I thought
after Knight c5 I'm doing perfectly fine
if he takes I don't think this would be
good but I just get this Bishop and a5
before it comes very quickly I think as
994 is very pretty but in the Soviet
school of chess it's called the
decoration right
like doesn't really do anything for the
house probably he shouldn't take but
then he can't get his Knight to e4 and
so I feel like I'm doing well I have
like nine a4 and c3 coming and so some
annoying ideas so much attacking
potential for black yes yeah for sure
well okay he played night before trying
to play Knight d5 I play Knight f6 and
this move comes with a hidden threat
because I'm covering the d5 square and
then I'm also threatening a5 when his
knight just doesn't have a good square
so he wonders here with h3 so nice move
like it's disguise you're threatening g4
which is also a threat right oh yeah
yeah I'm definitely wanting to take the
pawn but just a double threat h3 or
rogue g1 are just blunders because of
this move I think he had to play rook to
d1 according to the engine this was best
and then I can take on b4 take on g4 and
I I think I'm just up a pawn mm-hmm
looks good for a black maybe he has some
small compensation but probably nothing
serious yeah in any case he plays h3 oh
yeah we were analyzing g5 earlier this
might have been also interesting I'm not
sure exactly how black should get the
advantage here I was thinking Knight e4
in the game but then 95 is kind of a
critical yeah we were looking at this
earlier I think too extreme right
insurance easily what black should do
here you probably have to move the Queen
yeah if I take here because the Knights
gonna lie on e6 right something like or
risk yeah you can even take on a six
okay seven he can play him take the rook
what's that he can take clothes just
hang it yeah I can't defend the pawn so
yeah that's actually kind of sad
oh wait but you take advantage of the g5
fun like 94 in h4 of g1 yeah but I'm
just I'm down a pawn I don't know if I'm
gonna be better here yeah no reason to
go for this Lane
yeah probably something just like Queen
d6 take stakes and then I'm hitting the
g5 pawn and in the queen of Queen B for
I think we felt this endgame would just
be really nice for black because F pawn
ends up hanging and then I get 96 and
then Bishop c5 you never get five and
should be a win I don't know he doesn't
seem to have any counter play here so
yeah g5 not quite working Rick do you
want is probably just the only way to
really keep the game going
h3 a5 and it's just over because Knight
a - I just break with b4 and already
that's when you know it's bad when the
in tombs is just giving up all this is a
built in chest face engine which yeah
most high quality but of course this is
this is blacks points
he tried Knight d3 which is the only
other logical move but of course with
the night hanging it's like you're
always either looking to move the Queen
with tempo or defend it with tempo a
queen b7 night f2 he's still in the game
although b4 is probably dangerous but 95
is just much more to the point and
easier just hitting his queen
defending mine and attacking the bishop
and so this is just just lost Roy he
just loses the piece I took on e3
and converted from here pretty easily so
yeah I was like I mean it was a tough
game
in the middle I definitely feel like I
very topsy-turvy game only like 24 moves
yeah I really just kind of you know I
was a little bit lazy with Bishop e7 I
was just kind of you know hoping he
makes a mistake for me I don't have to
like try to induce it but the direct
approach c5 I think would have just been
clearly better even though we're trading
some pieces I feel like this position is
just so comfortable and easy for black I
should have done this so kind of a rocky
start but okay I mean I did find the
kind of only way to not lose and well
immediately he made a mistake and like
you know I was unable to equalize so all
right I'll take it
it's true let me save this okay we can
move this up okay are we gonna cut the
recording or now just keep it on okay
and yeah you can make a new border okay
well I'm super a jet lag I know people
can who are watching who can tell is
this a real time 10:30 1003 yeah okay as
I woke up at 7 a.m. today I was really
tired when I played my game so I'm gonna
try and keep this quick
can I just I just make moves ok I'll try
and get through the whole game without
needing to look at the score sheet under
30 moves I play a London because what
else he played okay so he played he 6d v
III and he played c5 you're also playing
like 1700 here yeah my actually my
opponent is someone who I'd met last
year older Romanian guy who he
recognized me last year from YouTube
which is interesting like he's watched
almost all my st. Louis chess club
YouTube videos and he told me after we
played this game then he watched the
video
on the London or videos on the London
but you forgot everything which is good
for me it's ironic though cuz one of the
videos that I do on the London is called
games you should know by hearts rare and
it's not something you should forget
anyway you might see five this is
already a kind of an unusual move order
and I thought for a moment here should I
play like mega 3 or C 3 or 92 1 for C 3
mainly because I wanted to keep these
Queen G 4 options open if I play and I
have 3 it stopped any Queen G 4 options
also C 3 is played because if he plays
Queen b6 I can play Queen B 3 and then
usually this is a nice way to meats and
seafood right yeah and as long as he
doesn't have like Bishop f5 then it's ok
right so I'm back oh yeah well can all
be arrow keys I can click on notation -
ah what's going on I think this thing
might be mana on a key actually oh
really
yeah might be on like that if the key or
something that's all good ok yeah so
it's not broken yet
ok so we got to this position so I'm you
still using leech s so this is first
this is a blast from the past
just this was my like best friend until
I discovered leech s um
but okay I'm still friends with with
chests base anyway he played he played
Bishop d6 here mhm
which mean you can click this green
button if you want him ok nice no which
made queen g4 really tempting or even
some line like take and then Queen g4
mmm-hmm I was debating I thought he
plays g6 and usually in these lines and
I wants to come to c3 oh I thought
because I've committed to pawn c3
I didn't know so I didn't go for it
I stay in my comfort zone I played
Bishop g3 and there's still a lot of
potential to transpose into someone like
me minds if he plays 18 out of 6 for 96
but he didn't do that he took which is
maybe already dubious but then I
realized that the sort of position it's
like a caro-kann exchange variation
right or you like trade early and you
get this like Karlsbad structure mm-hmm
but because he's played this east sixer
lee usually you don't want to do that in
Carroll cotton like you wanted developed
uh yeah light sweet Bishop comes out so
okay I'm happy here yeah what did he do
he played a weird move here yeah he
played a really weird move try and guess
his next move is it be five you know
okay no that was just okay because
you're not like a bat though just you
were hovering over the squirrels are
kind of club level player would make be
six yeah oh wow I think it was a French
player yeah he wanted to trade off the
bishop right be off but I have Queen a
for Chad yeah so he he's not threatening
[ __ ] of a six so my eyes kind of lit up
when he played b6 given that okay if if
he's threatening Bishop a6 I should
allow it because right he's threatening
to plunder this is the moment where you
just play Knight f3 quickly and hope he
just like yeah but I didn't want to play
Knight of three because I still wanted
Queen g4 options I want to have my queen
Terry foreign bases in G ports in some
cases so I played what I thought was the
most flexible move ninety-two and then
he started like shaking his head here so
that I think he realized Bishop a6 was
not playable any plate nine of six and
then I know if I told you this but I
I just finished like making a course on
the London I'm specifically tactics in
the London oh it's not it's not released
yet hi Jess it's coming out like next
month I prepare like a lot of positions
related to this this early b6 where it's
just just so weakening for black yeah I
was looking for ways to take advantage
of this somehow prevent him from
castling obviously like Queen a4 and it
should be five our candidate moves
I played Bishop b5 yeah he doesn't have
a good way to well he has Bishop d7 eyes
and that's why I didn't play Bishop e5
directly after b6 right but I realized
after Bishop e5 okay Bishop d7 is really
the only logical move if I want to I
could take on g6 but then we get some
line like this where neither side can
counsel then it's weird I didn't want to
go for this so his his bad Bishop
becomes a good Bishop right so I went
for this realizing I could just play
Bishop d3 here I just pull back and his
Bishop on g7 is misplaced and I actually
keep initiative it looks like I've
wasted time moving my bishop twice but
now his bishop on g6 is undefended and
he has to make some decision here what
to do with the bishop mm-hmm so what did
he play I think he played Queen c7
mm-hmm which is logical yeah play Knight
f3 then we continued developing he'd
played knight c6 mm-hmm I'm starting to
forget but I'm still remembering Queen
e2 yeah a lot of times in London it's a
fight for this e5 square as white I'd
probably just wanted to stick a knight
in d5 and be happy right as black he
wants to castle and play e5 before I can
castle but that would take too many
moves so I was feeling pretty
comfortable here
but you play this wrong if you played 9
h5 which i think is the best move a
simple idea of just taking on g3 with
the bytes mm-hmm and I really wanted to
keep the tension between the bishops
I didn't want to give up the bishop here
yeah he's also threatening Knight f4 is
annoying so I saw this coming before I
played Queen e2 and I just thought I
could take which is what I did after
take and then just play G 33 yeah
but he's already like made some
accomplishments by trading off the
bishops and because it feels like I
should have like a better grip on the
position like slightly more space any
trade should be beneficial for black but
now I think he'd play the bad move what
would you play here is black
I feel just go back Knight f6 yeah I
think that's a bad move Oh cousin I have
six like the knight has no purpose thank
you
well it's better on than on page five
right that so that's true like I want to
play 95 next right I think he should
play g6g six makes sense because he
keeps the night I never can play g4 and
then he has long term ideas of like f6
and E 5 and the knight is actually
stable on h5 now this is like the qgd
where they play this early night h5 yeah
ships get traded that makes sense and
there's another line in the London like
where you I've shown this before on
streams where it like black plays this
early 9h 5 and then f6 is a very common
idea got six and g6 so but you must
still be happy here with white yeah I
would have played this yeah well I
probably would just castle play rook e1
and try and prevent e5 but he didn't go
for that he played I played g3 so he did
not do that he played nine f6 back
mm-hmm which i think is just a
positional mistake like choosing the
wrong plan oh and then I was happy I
played 95 right away mm-hmm just putting
the pressure yeah now you just get this
bind yeah no it's a nice bind
yeah then I saw his his expression he
took a long time here and he looks sad
so that made me happy
I forgot whether you did did he Castle
or do you play rook c8 this is the time
where I have to find the notation yeah
we have like these Carbon Copy sheets
and they take the top copy so that the
bottom Katia is barely readable oh yeah
they need they need the ascending score
sheet that's true so they can probably
sell it on eBay
anyway ok-hee castled which is logical I
was hoping you and castle because he'd
be scared of some attack but he had no
fear I castled and then he played Bishop
see AIDS
well I'm developing which actually makes
sense I think this is a fine move
because you might want to play yeah
maybe Bishop d7 maybe someday 97 like
what else to do is black like there's so
few plans here in position like this cuz
he can never take on e5 that's true so I
thought this is reasonable
I play rook a eat one yeah to me it's a
sign that his position must be horrible
if he has to resort to this move yeah
it's pretty sad because like all my
pieces are just looks great coordinated
harmonious I want to play f4 yeah 4 G's
or g5
yeah the old pillsbury attack yeah but
something I don't know it wasn't that
easy maybe I made it look easy given
what happened in the game but I didn't
feel that easy during the game right
so I play off for wait did I play off
for I played that for you played Roxy
aids and then I think I made some
inaccuracy here I played another 3
mm-hmm which like the one small issue
for a white is e4 square is potentially
a weakness right if he ever can like
play 94 f5 mm-hmm and when I played out
of 3 I'm potentially giving him control
yeah at the later points and you play
the good move here he played a 97 which
I completely forgot about it now he just
wants to play 94.5 right and then I
realized that I made a mistake so what
if you had played like g4 on the g4 I
just in this position yeah I was
honestly just considering Knight to f3
in Queen G to g4 so I was predicting
that he would go for something like this
mmm-hmm with ideas of like f6 or even f5
maybe I should have considered this
maybe like rook F 3 here mmm
so okay f6 right away doesn't work cuz
my name is e6 pawn yeah maybe this was
possible because he can't move the F
pawn
yeah it looks and he's kind of stuck and
I want to play rook h3 I should have
considered this yeah I mean I'm a hacker
so this is yeah this is just yeah I
should have conserved this I just didn't
see his his plan o 90f 397 yeah and now
I want to ask you do you remember this
was back when like we were both around
18 remember attending the US chess
school oh yeah and Vaughn Whaley was
supposed to be the coach right but then
he got like deported or he didn't make
it through customs this is an amazing
story mistakenly told the customs agent
that he was visiting the u.s. to like
teach this chess camp and so I did like
customs that he had admitted that he was
here like getting paid and working but
he didn't have a work visa so they
deported him and he hasn't visited the
u.s. support is the right word if he's
opted in if he didn't make it through
customs though but he okay it's still
deportation uh yeah I feel like because
he was on he was Alliance you again JFK
or something or decline entry or
something yeah yeah anyway it was really
sad because then the replacement coach
for u.s. chess school was Craig Shahadah
which was actually it turned out to be a
great experience great job I think
knowing great no Greg was like oh yeah
yeah it was great I think Simon Williams
also got sent back not for the same well
I think you're right but recently for
some reasons yeah listen chess calm yeah
anyway over at the G us chess school
yeah Greg gave a lot
sure unlike the most random topic uh-huh
do you know what I'm leading to here
because he did a lot of he did some
interesting lectures
he also made us give lectures too yeah
yeah I like all these all these little
kids I remember you showed a game
against um if on the savage what was it
him I feel like you showed a game
against some junior ooh but I I don't
remember yeah I couldn't was a long time
ago someone Darwin Young I showed ya
some great gifts but Greg he gave a
bunch of lectures it's always like
anyway the lecturer Greg gave was
admitting mistakes
mm-hm and basically when you play a move
your opponent plays a move you realize
you've made a mistake and you revert and
just move back like undoing your move
yeah and he showed like a bunch of
examples like that and then I got to
this position I realize okay that
lecture came to mind I realized probably
the best move here for a white is night
back to d2 yeah stop 94 it's important
moment yeah because I mean strong
players make mistakes all the time and
the point is just not to make your
position worse once you write a mistake
just have no shame keep playing the game
I mean if anything your opponent who's
lower rated will just gain confidence
and that's great because then there are
a lot more likely to blunder when
they're confident so yeah I think it's a
nice move yeah well it's just keeping
all the tension and I I actually thought
he would play knight c6 quickly here I'm
thinking that okay I I would maybe
repeats but he actually took a lot of
time he realized that oh maybe he
tricked me and got some confidence he
wants to make full use of the position
but I was still feeling good after 92 I
was feeling bad like around when he
played 97 but your position still looks
great again it's full control yeah and
he started playing weird moves okay his
next is the confidence his next four
moves are like incredibly
weird because they had nothing to do
with like him like they see it it seemed
like an attempt to improve the position
but he just let me attack and he is
there was no focus on the Kings side oh
I see
so first move he played was Europe to c7
okay
which okay maybe small improvement or
something I don't know I play queen g2
and then the next move was the issue is
like in this structure like the Carlsbad
or reversal is bad you know normally
they just want to play b5 before right
yeah
but they just they can't ever have that
does this plan right so it's not clear
what to do I thought that somehow like I
thought he played rook c7 with idea of
Knight see 896 mm-hmm but it's just too
slow because I'm gonna get like threats
with g4 g 5 or something yeah but
normally in the structure you want your
night on g6 and f6 to control efore
right but okay he played another random
move a5 she gave me another tempo I
played Queen h3 wait till I play Queen
Age 3
yeah I played Queen Street and then it
would be great if you touch this no six
no then he played rook e8 so it was some
deep positional idea to like trade off
lights for bishops yeah maybe it's
playable um I just I continues improving
I play Knight to f3 and then he played
okay now he has to defend because I'm
threatening all sorts of dirtiness with
Knight g5 right so he put h6 and when
you play h6 my eyes lit up because I
thought I had a winning combination here
I thought I could no boy do you see it
well I would love to just either play
Knight g5 or take on f7 then can i g5
those are the two candidate moves
yeah yeah good time today I know
I immediately yeah if you want to like
calculate this and pause your video and
suggest or try and find the best
continuation for whites feel free to do
so I took maybe 15 minutes in this
position it took a long think I played
the the opening in the middle game
relatively quickly up until here so I
immediately just thought and I take f7
is winning because my take f7 mm-hmm
King take a seven rook take you six
right then Bishop g6 check no Knight to
g6 wait Knight takes you six oh sorry
yeah yeah 95 check Oh 85 right right so
blind I take f7 Kingi f7 Network take
you six I just thought it should be
winning but then I realized after rook
take you six against Bishop c8 that's so
annoying cold shower yeah you probably
didn't see this but you would probably
find the ship c8 if we got to that
position right just to illustrate
further yeah and there's nothing there
for what you think I don't think so
because I sock a piece and the Queen's
are getting traded I wanted to make like
95 work but 95 just King King g8 and my
rook is skewered to the Queen his
knights are covering a lot of squares
and then when he takes on h3 he's also
hitting the rook on exactly so I don't
even like win the b6 pawn right so that
was a bit annoying so that was the first
candidate moved and I take a seven but
rejected because of this line I also
have some ideas like Knight take f7 King
take a seven and then Knight g5 mmm-hmm
there's a reason why I rejected it
they're giving up a lot of nights but
yeah maybe he just takes and it's it's
too messy like it's it's too risky where
it's it's unclear and if he survives he
could be winning so yeah immediate
Knight g5 looks so 95 immediately looks
nice
can make the move but I didn't play it
and this is where my Jet Li like looking
back on the game just because I'm so
sleep-deprived I don't remember what I
was thinking oh I've rejected it because
not not because of a chick g5 but
because of rookie fades oh I didn't see
how I make progress here and now he
wants to take and play 94 because now F
sevens defendant I was calculating like
lions so if I move back to like night GF
3 he has 94 yeah
this is not a position where you should
go back I mean I I feel like H g5 isn't
a threat yet is because like 90 for me
you'll have like rook F for a cage for
maybe but but it's muddy but he also
doesn't have to take so there's no
wanted to make something like g4 work
and I take f7 work but yeah I don't know
so I didn't see anything there so I
realized that he's a media tactics they
don't lead too much so why not bring
something more into attack I play g4
yeah I use the hook yeah yeah our games
had similar themes kind of different
yeah well I was hesitant to play g4 cuz
Knight e4 and he gets something I guess
I was too I was trying to be too
controlling where I wanted like full
dominance right but I guess it was okay
to give him something cuz a line like
this if he plays Knight e4 which he
didn't do I think I just go for g5 g5
yeah or even like I could take on e4 and
then 92 and go after the e4 pawn so
there there might be a few options there
but if I'm not mistaken in this position
he played the losing move maybe it's
already losing I don't know but he
played push basics uh which walks into
Bishop take a six they should take a six
rook take a six yeah he spent so much
time trying to get his rook to a six
that it's not it's just that it was
completely the other play it doesn't
have time to come back and defend so
this is a time to strike this is again
we're like doing this whole video course
in like preparing all these tactics
specifically in the London really helped
because I had all these like concepts in
mind about keeping initiative going for
destruction a lot of examples we're
fresh about liking side attacks like
this yeah and here is about combining a
few different resources and taking
advantage of the fact that box pieces
are just out of play in terms of being
able to defend the Kings side so the
moves to start with of course is g5 yeah
and now after taking on g5 did you see
what happened no I didn't ah looks lorry
looks bad yeah but actually is some
natural moves here uh-oh maybe I could
just take the pawn
taking with pawn might be simpler than
what I did
oh my gosh and then I can take on a
seven-night of seven right I did not
even see that that's double check mates
okay I play the way more complicated
option I don't know why I didn't see
this so wait you said there's a double
checkmate
double check needs this is more
beautiful than oh wait that's not the
what am I seeing
King e8 or King g8 that's not even it's
this is still crushing I mean Queen h8
and I feel like Jesus must be that's
embarrassing I thought this is checkmate
because if here then Queen h8 yeah and
if oh my gosh would know
if King g8 I assume by the sudden yeah
okay so that was that was probably the
cleanest twin I did something a bit
fancier after after he played H take g5
mmm-hmm
I played the mediate and I take off
seven nominees because after King take
off seven I was so fixated on this
previous idea that I wanted to play
earlier where there were bishops on the
board to play Brooke take you six mmm
now he doesn't have the bishop to play
Bishop C eights yeah Queen take you six
Knight g5 so looks pretty good yeah yeah
this is I it should just be winning um I
think the best try for him is Queens
Yates
you just took on a four I think
forgetting about 95 oh I can't just
resigned I see wow that was abrupt so
yeah I finished very abruptly I think
you just assumed that's like these heart
disease punch in the face moves might
take f7 rook take you six it's not over
here at least I didn't see like a
clear-cut win but I saw so much
initiative I was gonna play 95 but can
you take and take on our six if he goes
back I was gonna play 95 in this
position because I wanna i want my pawn
in g5 it's one of the points oh sure
oh there's another funny line actually
just show after wait a minute
I go back one mmm-hmm yeah in this
position if he plays g4 mm-hmm kind of
an interesting counter-attack I would
play 95 wait a minute
no I would play Knight g5 in g5 um let's
say King g8 and then there's this nice
move as my queen so attacked queen d3
now as Queens hanging is rooks hanging
I'm threatening rook takes f6 yeah so
some move like this okay I could take
the rook but I could just take on f6 and
it's yeah h7 this coming
so yeah g4 didn't work so yeah probably
the best line would have been Queen g8
and then I assume this is just crushing
because queen h8 ideas yeah like if King
g8 I just take on g5
yeah it looks over night at 7 Queen 8
shape now should just be yeah winning
for whites so the first round game still
super tired yeah you just got to Europe
so here I just yeah getting used to I
mean I come into London three days ago
and arrived in Romania yesterday so I'm
tired and it's it's late for me even
though it's like it's 2:30 p.m. Chicago
time I've was old like I woke up at 6
today went back to sleep and woke up at
like 7:00 so one you get me back with
every round we play yeah
now the question is will the internet be
good enough here to upload a YouTube
video I'm not sure about that we'll see
we'll see but there are we have options
lessons Dropbox and TeamViewer it still
has to get online
well finagle it yeah anyway we will see
you guys if you're watching this in the
future we were successful and you're not
and that's kind of sad ok all right guys